So our friends play a game called "Dead Body."
And it's where one of you pretends to be a dead body
and the other person has to get you to the bed
comfortably.  Without hurting you.
Brad: "Right."
So we're going to start with me as a dead body
and since Brad is stronger than me
I'm going to start on top of him and he has to
get me all the way there without hurting me.
So I'm going to take off my glasses.
So I'm just gonna--
You have to lay down.  Yeah.
Ok which way should I lay down?
Lay down face up.
No.  But yeah, handicap on your stomach.
And so you're--
So I'm a dead body.
So I have to imagine that you're dead?
Yeah.  You have to get me to the bed comfortably without hurting me.
How much time am I allowed to like, cry?
While I think about your death?
None.
No, that makes for a boring video.
*sobbing*
No one wants to see white male tears.
All right.
Oh, my neck just cracked.
See?  I'm just helping you.
Yeah.
Even though you're--after you're dead.
Oh, Congo is coming!
Oh he gonna eat my dead body.
Ok, so...
Oh hi Congo!
Ahahaha!
You want to help, Congress?
So this, uh.  This isn't going to work.
The way I was trying this.
Ok.
So I'm going to back down.
And I'm gonna--I'm gonna roll you off.
Ok.  Don't roll me over the cat.
If you hurt the cat you're disqualified too.
That's not Congress, that's your pony tail.
Oh, okay.
Where's Congress?
I don't know, I'm a dead body.  I can't see anything.
Oh, that hurts my hands.
That hurts your hand?
You're not supposed to talk.
But if I'm in pain I gotta tell you.
Well how much did it hurt?  Not that much right?
Not a lot but it's still painful.
There.
I feel like this is too easy for you.
This is too easy for me?  No!
I feel like I should be holding weights as like a handicap.
No, you started on my back.  That's a good handicap.
Ah!
What hurts?
It's cause I worked out the other day so
*loud grunting*
It's still tough.  You're not helping.
Oh no, watch out for Congress!
Watch out for Congress!
Ow!
*laughing*
Overreactions.
No, you hit me!
Now you have to put me on the bed nicely too.
Right?
Good job!
One hand on a kitty.
That's the way you're supposed to be buried.
Good job.
I feel like that was way too easy for you.
Okay!  My turn!
Cat Intermission.
We have a new cat!
She's a big one.
And she's so cute.
And her name is Ghost.
And she likes to meow a lot.
Yeah, she's a meower.
New kitten challenge:  everybody gets a new kitten.
Everybody just gets a new kitten.  That's the challenge.
I don't know how I'm going to do this.
Brad is heavy.
Ok.
You can lie down.
I'm not not winded.  I am winded.
Ok.
So it wasn't like super easy.
Just lay down.  Just lay down.
On your back.
I'm gonna lay down.
You don't need to--
You don't need to keep telling me.
Lay down.
I'm already laying down.
Be a dead body.  Dead bodies don't have their legs like that.
Your dead body is not good.  Ok.
You're going to critique my dead body?
Yeah!
It's like that movie with Daniel Radcliffe.
The farting one?
Yeah, I'm going to like fart.
Don't do that.
I'm going to kill you with my fart.
This is just a challenge where you take off my shirt.
Ugh!
Oh God.
I feel like I'm going to get hurt.
That's not...that's uh...
That seems like it's bound to happen.
Why are your shoes coming off?
I'm not doing anything.  I'm dead.
I shouldn't have squatted yesterday.
Haha.
Pretty good!  Pretty good!
This is a new kind of workout!
Ahh!
*grunting*
Ow!
Haha.
I'm sorry!
This isn't how I lay in a bed!
You're going to pull off my pants.
That's how I want to be buried.
Naked, with a cat.
Ok.
Hahaha.
Oh, I scared the cat away!
Haha.
Let's move the pillow to you!
Move the pillow to me!
Wow.
All that crossfit.
It's the hip thrusts, is what do it.
Without the hip thrusts, that wouldn't have happened.
You would have had to use some sort of pulley device.
You're in your casket sir, alive now.
That's the "Dead Body" game...that our friends play.
I don't know why.
I'm a zombie now!
I don't ever want to play that game again.
And you can check out Brad's channel by clicking anywhere on his face.
Click on my face.
I'm not dead, I swear.